Speaker 1: I have some incredible video to play
for you of Texas gubernatorial candidate Beto
O'Rourke saying to a member in the audience who
was laughing when he talked about gun violence.
It's not funny to me, Motherfer. And I have to
tell you, I love this. We actually I've been
saying. These people on the right, the currency
they trade in is ignorance, reactionary ideology
and humiliation, unfortunately. And Beto O'Rourke
humiliated a Greg Abbott supporter who laughed out
loud. Everybody heard it when Beto described the
killing of 19 kids and two teachers in Ville de
Texas, and Betto reacted in a way that is entirely
appropriate given the circumstances. Take a look
at this. This video going viral.
Speaker 2: That now 11 weeks
since we lost 19 kids and there are two teachers
shot to death with a weapon originally designed
for use in combat, legally purchased by an 18 year
old who did not try to obtain one when he was 16
or 17, but followed the law. That's on the books,
ladies and gentlemen, that says that you can buy
not one. You can buy two or more if you want to,
a AR 1500s of rounds of ammunition and take the
weapon that was originally designed for use on
the battlefields in Vietnam to penetrate an enemy
soldiers helmet at 500 feet and knock him down
dead up against kids at five feet. It may be funny
to you, but it's not funny to be open. We saw.
Speaker 1: Oh, the tone. And he swore. Oh, well,
when Trump swears, they love it. This is sort
of the only appropriate reaction to someone
laughing at a horrifying story of gun violence.
Sometimes you got to speak their language. I mean,
these are sick people. This is the currency
they trade in. And reports from inside the event
are that every single Abbott supporter in the room
was laughing as if this were some kind of joke.
What happened in Texas? I would love to see more
Democrats just being able to speak out like this.
It's genuine. This is better and
not cowering. When these right wing,
borderline domestic terrorists start behaving
the way that they behave. Are deaths funny? Is
gun violence. Funny? Funny how? What's funny about
it? Now, this is a really important race in Texas.
Beto O'Rourke is challenging the incumbent lunatic
Republican Governor Greg Abbott. The polling is
not tremendously great for battle right now, but
I think this one is very much worth fighting for.
If you look at an average of recent polls, Abbott
is ahead by just shy of eight points right now.
Abbott's got about half of the vote. Beddoes got
about 42%. So this is I mean, listen, let's not
sugarcoat it. This is not the easiest margin
to overcome, but it's certainly possible and
it would be absolutely extraordinary to be able to
take this one from Republicans. So that's what's
going on in Texas. Good for Barreto, guys. This is
this is the understandable frustration that we all
should have with people who laugh at gun violence.
They laugh and they want to do nothing about guns.
Doors. They'll talk about windows, sinks, showers
and toilets they'll talk about, but not guns.